science breakthroughs from science
mission instead of using one or more
transcription factors researchers have
used small molecule chemicals to
generate neurons from skin cells and
have published two papers in the journal
Cell Stem Cell in the first paper
scientists disrupted the fibroblast
genes and induced neural genes and add a
small molecule to convert my fibroblast
to neurons in the second paper skin
cells from other MERS patients were
treated with small molecules to generate
neurons thus providing further proof for
the use of small molecules to generate
neural stem cells next butters in the
journal Nature communications show that
macrophages a form of white blood cells
after ischemic injury secrete week which
induces canonical nf-kappa B mediated
myogenic progenitor cell proliferation
and repair however macrophages also
secret another factor called cd163 that
binds to be preventing its action and
allowing for cell differentiation action
of cd163 is further confirmed by
knockout mouse model where uninhibited
action of twix leads to prolonged muscle
regeneration for more news visitors at
www science mission common science
mission facebook page thanks for
watching